oh God that's horrible
[Laughter]
you can texture of that rank that is big
Phil
you it
[Music]
hi I'm Lily Allen and this is snack Wars
for lad Bible UK versus us why are we
doing UK versus yes I don't know you
tell me
I am English as you can tell from my
accent but I live or reside in
America so I suppose that's probably why
they've asked me to do this so that I
can um
annoy everyone
[Laughter]
Mini flumps
cotton candy I'm taking it this is
English this is not made in America
written on the front of it so I
recognize those not in a packet
obviously I know what cotton candy is
called candy floss here
I think I've seen these before in a bowl
of children's party yeah see if it
reminds me of mine's bigger in size as
well
just that's how it is sometimes
that's what life is sometimes that is
just life
it's the mini mini plump yeah I guess
the full-size flump is it's just the
same but big
yeah it's coming back to me now
definitely had these before
let's have some of this
yep I mean it is quite compressed
oh you can taste the chemicals in it you
can smell them too
what flavor is that
[Laughter]
thing
insulation that's what it looks like it
actually looks like that looks yeah
what's up in your roof isn't it
the mini thumps every time
I know this packaging it's a Greg
sausage roll
not warm
the American thing better not be warm
otherwise that's an unfair advantage
a really unappetizing looking hot dog
should I eat some of this yeah that is a
promise isn't it oh God that's horrible
the texture of that rank that is big
Phil
even in its cold sad state
um every time sorry Greg's is far
superior I hope this isn't going to be
the same the whole way through but I'll
just say the English thing otherwise
I've I've messed up I'm living it living
in the wrong place
oh my God what's your take on the
vegetarian one
not for me
I like a big meaty sausage
I already know who wins this one
not videos
Hot Cheetos
and we have
pickled onion monster munch
I think the giant one our giant ones
cheetahs is normal regular what are you
doing
[Laughter]
foreign
what's it
these monster munch your favorite yeah
do you know Monster Munch pickled onion
flavor it was on my rider
so I mean lots of these
um
yeah what is your take on the giant
Walmart
it's inconvenient
demonstrate obviously I put a whole one
in there and that was quite a lot for
one bite yeah so the other option is to
bite it in half
yeah I'm not good for a lady I want a
lady-sized
this is lad Bible isn't it that's
probably good for the lads not so good
for the ladies
so what's the score still wins yeah
oh interesting okay
we've got iron brew and caffeine free
root beer
it's like a sort of heavy heavier Fanta
I guess you should say that
I just did say that
do you know what that reminds me of is
the dentist when you wash your mouth out
when you have to go just put it in there
that's what that is
sorry
England's one again but that is Scotland
that's you yeah yeah yeah that is very
responsive I can't say England and talk
about right iron Brew in the same
sentence yeah
I'm gonna burp now because that's fizzy
I mean it's fine
okay
Lucky Charms
okay all right okay yeah
porridge yes yes
I do quite like porridge but you know I
sort of uh not like this
I've kind of spoke too soon it's
actually all right
hmm
it's not that bad
this is sort of um
thing I would have liked eaten in my
youth I guess when I went to America
this has been exciting lucky chance
looking very nice
quite decent
I'd say the Lucky Charms is going to
take this round does the milk turn a
weird color
yesterday was going blue it's in parts
oh
okay so what's
what is that pumpkin spice latte okay
interesting and
yes meat extract isn't it I used to
drink this all the time when I was a kid
my granddad used to make me eat it
it's kind of like what am I right it's
same sort of consistency and looks
[Music]
It's All Coming Back
it tastes like
watery gravy nice
uh
it's overall
[Laughter]
not my chickens
I don't know what is what is
it's not in any way appealing this is
far more appealing the UK takes it again
on that level this time the beef paste
okay
I am
um pleased to report that the UK won
um
is all right
except I have to go back to America now
and eat their horrible food
[Laughter]
we can give a tooth stick with you
okay
oh my God horrific just like oh God
laughs